en bolivia el día de la raza ha sido
reemplazado hace diez años por el día de
la descolonización porque el ex
presidente evo morales consideraba que
ese término es discriminatorio con los
pueblos indígenas pues bien el día de la
descolonización se recordará hoy en
bolivia con concentraciones de grupos
indígenas y sectores sociales para
reivindicar el uso de la wiphala la
bandera de los indígenas que en los
últimos días ha estado en el centro de
la polémica pues grupos opositores de
santa cruz se han negado a izarla en un
acto oficial mediante los voceros del
más se sabe que el presidente luís ar se
va a encabezar estos actos en honor de
la wiphala que se han denominado el oui
palazo en las ciudades de cochabamba
santa cruz y la paz las tres principales
urbes del país por otro lado los voceros
del más han señalado que esta
concentración no solamente busca
reivindicar la wiphala es decir la
bandera de los indígenas sino también
dar un mensaje de respuesta a los grupos
opositores que las últimas horas han
protagonizado protestas
del presidente luis arce particularmente
en santa cruz